sea pdte el número de personas en la
playa de copacabana en río de janeiro de
horas después de la medianoche en un día
específico
qué significa la proposición de 5 menor
de 9
esto es el número de personas cinco
horas después de la medianoche
antes de responder las preguntas vamos a
pensar lo que nos están diciendo
el número de personas cinco horas
después de la medianoche es menor que el
número de personas nueve horas después
de la medianoche veamos la primera
respuesta la hora en que había cinco
personas en la playa es más temprano que
la hora en la que había nueve personas
pero aquí el 5 y el 9 se refiere al
número de personas pero aquí la entrada
es la hora nuestra función
toma una entrada
dentro de nuestra función p
y obtenemos una salida que es p dt
qué es el número de personas a la hora
de después de la medianoche o sea esto
es igual al número
de personas
de horas
después de la medianoche
así que este cinco son cinco horas
después de la medianoche o sea las 5 am
definitivamente podemos descartar esta
primer respuesta ya que no estamos
hablando de la hora estamos hablando del
número de personas 5 horas después de la
medianoche y 9 horas después de la
medianoche
vamos con la siguiente las 5m es más
temprano que las 9 am bien pues esta es
una declaración correcta pero se refiere
a cómo medimos el tiempo si la 5a m es
más temprano que las 9 m eso es correcto
pero no tiene que ver con el número de
personas de las que habla nuestra
proposición así que la descartamos y
veamos la última había más personas en
la playa a las 9 am a ver veamos
personas en la playa a las 9 m
justamente es lo que se refiere esto que
está aquí que las que había a las 5 am
qué es esto qué se refiere
y lo cual es cierto había más personas
nueve horas después de la medianoche que
cinco horas después de la medianoche
esta es la respuesta correcta